[Musique]
abahilleur est au questionnement après
l'accident de la route mortelle sur la
d307 c'est dans la nuit du 22 au 23
décembre que s'est produit le drame
lorsqu'un conducteur a perdu le contrôle
de son véhicule entrant en collision
avec une famille de quatre personnes les
tests d'alcoolmi et de stupéfiants du
conducteur responsable de l'accident se
sont révélés négatif dans les colonnes
du Parisien ce mardi les habitants et le
maire de la commune s'interrogent sur la
sécurité de cet axe le président de
l'île de loisirs de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline José Cachin a annoncé sa
démission vendredi 22 décembre une
conséquence de la crise de gouvernance
qui pèse sur la plus grande base de
loisirs d'Île-de-France cette annonce
intervient au même moment que celle du
retrait de la région Île-de-France du
Syndicat de Gestion de la Base de plein
air et la sortie de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en ivine de ce même
syndicat à rambouillé à l'occasion du
réveillon le collectif Noël pour tous
soutenu par de nom nombreuses
associations a convié près de 280
bénévoles et convives isolés pour
partager un repas de Noël solidaire le
nouveau directeur général de Pôle emploi
en visite dans les Yvelines vendredi 22
décembre Tibao guoui s'est rendu dans le
département pour une visite sur le thème
de l'accompagnement des entreprises dans
leurs besoins de recrutement et
l'accompagnement renforcé des
allocataires du RSA à cette occasion il
s'est rendu à l'agence Pôle emploi de
trappe et au centre d'action sociale de
guyencour
[Musique]